I first discovered this guy he had about
20 000 subscribers and I said I'm
getting all Kelly vibes from this guy
he's deliberately seeking out these
young impressionable women educated
women of real high value and high
self-respect who are going places in
their own life and don't need a man
they're not picking this guy he's
picking the pretty ones who didn't have
a dad who are struggling and I watched a
Jordan Peterson clip where he talked
about men who are Psychopathic and put
extreme confidence to young women women
will mistake that confidence for
confidence women read confidence as a
marker of competence the Psychopaths
mimic competence and the psychopath
comes in and pretends that he's a
productive generous reciprocator but
he's not he's just an instrumental
manipulator but he can get away with it
because there's enough wealth generated
by the Cooperators so that there's a
space for someone to exploit the system
and that works particularly well on
naive young women and of course they get
exploited by people like that and they
think well that's what men are like